[Music]
and just doing their job news who
submitted by wonderboy a school district
found that many of its teachers have a
problem with the study ants that speak
mostly Spanish what tips teach warn
America goddamnit speak American who
cares if they're just cleaning the
toilet and they're just speak they want
to speak Spanish but when you're yelling
Spanish into the toilet it goes all over
the place so this is happening in
Florida all are speaking about weird
cube in Cuban Spanish that's why I'd be
against that Spanish it's faster
different dialects and it's kind of
reggaeton II a little bit yeah reggae
Tony yeah forget it
moving on you got this I could I get
dawn and it's a tone in their voice you
got it you good let's go girl yeah
they're just gonna hit me that hard
story time okay thank you do your job
alright so this this school district
they had this survey that was answered
by more than 4,000 employees back in May
and it was submitted anonymously so they
can't even talk to the certain employees
I have issues with this but they found
out they're afraid of being racist so
they said that it's impossible to know
who wrote I would be fired for not being
able to communicate after years on the
job or who declared English should be a
mandatory requirement for hiring
exclamation mark this is America um so
yeah they can't really speak to these
people I mean I get that I understand
cuz what if you need help you're like
hey excuse me and then like they're like
sorry
they were just mad at them for just
speaking Spanish to in general like when
I worked at a restaurant they didn't
want the cooks to speak Spanish because
like they ate some of the employees
thought that the cooks were talking [ __ ]
about them based but that's so
self-centered to me I know because like
I could be talking to her about [ __ ]
hair and then people are killed she's
talking
saying why they made that rule because
it was a corporate but for the job one I
get it because it's like if you need
like wheat joe said like if you need to
communicate some [ __ ] like you can't
like I don't mind if it's like their
bile evil yeah yeah that's their doing
their job and they're there they're
talking in whatever language yeah like
cool I don't care but if I'm like hey
I'm gonna need help here hey did you get
that or hey over there that needs to
happen and they're like wait what and
you're like what the [ __ ] like so that
is a lot of the concerns that were
expressed where the fact that they can't
communicate with some people because
they don't speak Spanish but the thing
is that there are the every single
supervisor that supervises the
custodians they all are bilingual so
they can always communicate with the
employees right yeah but that's what
that is a concern for some people but
the concerning feedback is the ones that
are saying like this is America
yeah communicate speaking English oh you
should not be speaking Spanish when
you're at work like talk to you yeah
exactly so that's why if they're just
saying like dude that's racist yeah 100%
I had a boss that was like that um she
was from Iowa and [ __ ] that [ __ ] I
already know [ __ ] test date not to say
that that's true chick [ __ ] that post
she was this older lady and they just
don't like how America's not all white
anymore exactly but they can deal with
that in their diary [ __ ] that's not my
problem
same thing happens at my nail salon
though when they speak the enemies um
like they're their ladies aren't a lot
of speak Vietnamese anymore in front of
us oh baby talking [ __ ] none of my
business dude I've always made it a
point like when I worked before
communicating at the mail saw even if
they're [ __ ] talking [ __ ] about me
that's pretty much their [ __ ] like they
could talk all the [ __ ] they want while
they're doing your nails yeah as long as
he doing a good job all right
they could be talking all this [ __ ] they
want and like literally like look I'm
picky like I'll be like oh that's wrong
or whatever they'll be like for this
[ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm like yeah this
[ __ ] [ __ ] is gonna get her nails
right you know
I don't really I guess my ego and my
feelings are not so minuscule that I'm
like oh I need to know what you're
saying yeah there's like me go to the
strip club and I get a lap dance and I'm
like what you're talking [ __ ] about me
yeah like you say the [ __ ] I don't care
they're terrified of bad Yelp reviews
yeah for sure cuz like they're scared of
those customers that are all that sucks
because um that really bothered me a lot
when my boss would come in and like
pretty much the majority of her
department were Hispanic and like we all
spoke Spanish when we were just just
talking about her like lunching your own
time breaking you don't even help you're
not even serving the public yeah
actually it's literally within like an
office in our department exactly we
weren't serving the public at all I was
just within us she's a bitter [ __ ] okay
so what she would say it's like whenever
we're trying to work and stuff and we're
talking about our own day I mean yes
we're working and get it but she'd be
like you know this is America we speak
English and that's it being like
speaking Spanish America anymore you
need to be speaking English this is
America the place where freedom of
speech you stop speaking the way you
want to speak you're like [ __ ] you
weren't here before you [ __ ] you it's
California Los Angeles yeah so then it
got to the point where she was she was
literally writing people up for speaking
Spanish I would've already a chart
because I would have been like HD [ __ ]
are like this bitch's race is fun
so it only bothers her that your speak
what she's from yeah it was cuz I mean
what are the [ __ ] cuz I don't give up
okay a little bit more about her though
side note is that this lady was racist
she's I felt like she was for sure
racist one Google two she needed a get
dick down cuz Sheen that she did not
have a manner from Spanish dick it's
because she loves Latino men and they
don't [ __ ] about an i cuz his [ __ ]
like I don't know what his big Spanish
Simon [ __ ] hate all of you guys she
didn't have any kid so she would always
like look down and talk [ __ ] on the
females that had kids
what's my stuff yes so unhappy and she
was like very like pastor prime right so
like she would always be so short there
was she like 33 nah
Bart Dellacroce dan she was a [ __ ]
she's gonna [ __ ] you I know how do you
feel it I'm extra salty because she kept
me on a per diem job for four [ __ ]
years
no baby you do not want to give me my
full-time benefits for four years you
know you you know what the crazy part is
that we would talk about these people we
think like oh it only happens like far
away from you but that should happen to
me too
and like it was like at a fitness
convention so it was like an influencer
that people know about I'm not gonna say
any names but literally oh I was
literally saying like to one of my
colleagues or whatever I was the cake he
passed me a computer in Spanish they're
telling him the password to a computer
in Spanish cause he knows Spanish I know
Spanish and they're just it's a comfort
thing I don't know and I was like lalala
and this guy walks by and he's like
speak [ __ ] English yeah [ __ ] and you
like at a convention it was literally an
insult he's not your boss
it was an influencer literally and what
did you say right and you would think
that a bad [ __ ] like [ __ ] it cursed
about in Spanish but I was literally so
taken back at the fact that this guy was
obviously racist I was like I knew you
were it's us but now you're just like
confirmed it like you have Mexican
followers like like I was literally like
I literally was like oh [ __ ] literally
it was so weird dude it was so he wasn't
joking she was not joking and like later
she would just walk by and like left and
I couldn't I feel like I couldn't even
say anything because this company I was
like this company's gonna like take me
out of my contract if I [ __ ] try to
make a big deal out of it cuz that was
like their golden boy
you know what I mean narrow [ __ ] down
guys don't do what are the fun you
weren't but yeah it was crazy and I was
just like it's it's insane how racist
people are behind closed doors you know
and now more openly like yeah and I
really thought like one day if that's
what could happen to me I [ __ ] go off
but you just saw huh like I was just
shocked as [ __ ] that's why you gotta
remember what you're gonna say like you
gotta have these imaginary fights with
racist people and then you have these
lines like a rapper you know and you
have these punchlines
so what it happens you go whoever
waiting for this [ __ ] the free
country I could say whatever
[ __ ] you but if you like these save
something bad and you pick the wrong one
like I'll to $4 tonight damn the coupon
you're saying uh yeah you know I really
like the most frustrating part it's like
their their argument is this is America
speak English it's like [ __ ] this is
America we're a melting pot of cultures
but generally we're about article of a
photo
you know what's tight that you should be
like this is America yeah we [ __ ] work
at the same place what the [ __ ] happened
you [ __ ] puta you're also speaking to
the lowest level of IQ you know like
they're not a great representation of
white people either literally are saying
those words that are coming out of their
mouths those are the people I am
addressing and I mean I like to think
because I always like to see both sides
of the coin I'm like yeah I mean you
don't like brown people in your country
maybe you want to keep this a white
country or whatever but Beach that's
very much your problem who Native
Americans were brown look but like I
think what a lot of white people and I
don't know but from their understanding
this is their country you know what I
mean and so like their thing is like it
was right and no I don't think it's even
a white person thing is just like this
is an ignorant person it's an ignorant
person thing to carry it is not a race
yeah and I think it's because like like
she's from Iowa right if she grew up
here in Southern California or a lot of
southwestern states like Mexican culture
is just a part of it it's been a part of
it for a long [ __ ] time so people
that are here still thinking it's just
that she really had such a fragile ego
that she really thought yeah we were but
deal with that [ __ ] people talk [ __ ]
about you period moved back to Iowa yeah
or you could hear people talk [ __ ] about
you we should go to Iowa and just speak
Spanish and see what happens take a
camera with us dude there was that there
was that video that was circulating
where there was a lady that was telling
this other lady to speak Spanish English
right and then this other white lady
came and in she was like
what the [ __ ] you don't stop you don't
bully people because they don't do that
chick doesn't know white people we like
they're like the minority shield yeah
thank you and their power to invade
other people's space because their life
sucks their own life sucks yeah it's a
power trip thing they're trying to last
you feel inferior in their own lives so
they try to take anything thank you the
same thing like why they keep trying to
suppress a gay rights and all that and
like it's their it's their [ __ ] life
Lee they just feel like they need to
like establish their superiority because
they feel so little inside well I see
that base they see their culture coming
under threat right so what they're used
to is everyone's speaking English and
that being a standard comfort thing yeah
and then like it's it's like so have you
heard of what white flight is no so in a
Sun you know why people they move away
when minorities come and then they want
to be in their own suburb and stuff like
that right so when their culture and
their area starts getting changed when
other people are moving they don't like
that she came here yeah she came into
art I mean yeah it's all I mean this
this happens all over laughs and they
don't know what it's like to be a
minority and this happens in Hawaii
actually it's reversed where white
people come to Hawaii and they tried to
live there and assimilate there and
they're just like what the [ __ ] they get
in they get in for like [ __ ] your big a
surprise because it's it's completely
flipped the other way over there and
they speak like the normal white English
and all the Hawaiians I speak pidgin
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]